et on va rester dans l'esprit olympique
si vous voulez bien le drapeau gay va
flotter sur l'hôtel de ville de montréal
pendant les jeux et françois cormier
c'est en quelque sorte un geste de
protestation mais également de
solidarité contre la loi anti gay qui a
été adopté par la russie par le
gouvernement poutine oui cette loi qui
interdit et je cite la propagande des
relations non traditionnels donc le
mercredi a annoncé sur nos ondes ce
matin qu'il emboîte elle pas finalement
à son homologue de saint jean terre
neuve il allait ici le drapeau qui
devant l'hôtel de ville de montréal ce
sera fait demain et il n'a pas il n'est
pas le seul d'ailleurs avoir suivi le
mouvement il ya déjà des maires
d'arrondissement montréal qui ont fait
la même chose dans devant des mairies
d'arrondissement il ya le maire watson à
ottawa le maire pedneault jobin à
gatineau également qu'ils l'ont fait
qu'ils vont le faire en fait et il y en
a un qui l'a déjà fait c'est régis
labeaume à québec dit oui tout de suite
quand on nous a appelés pour pour ici le
drapeau gay on a décidé de faire comme
tout le monde pour protester donc contre
cette loi guèye a également le roi le
mode stade qui sera éclairée aux
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel demain soir
alors je vous laisse entendre les maires
denis coderre est juste là bon
je vous avouer que cette loi homophobe
et des russes je vois qu'à saint-jean
terre-neuve on a mis en place un le
drapeau arc-en-ciel et moi je pense que
je vais faire la même chose je reprend
exactement les mots de 10
on va ici le drapeau de la fierté gay
prêt solidaire avec
toute la communauté gay et des comptes
selway tout à fait aux homophobes et
rétrogrades
sur un tout autre sujet maintenant
françois et à l'ancien maire de montréal
michael applebaum qui était de retour
devant les tribunaux aujourd'hui oui lui
et deux autres accusés dans cette
affaire finalement vous vous souvenez
que le maire applebaum avait été arrêté
au mois de juin là pour une vente de
terrains dans du côté de côte des neiges
notre dame de grâce donc le maire
applebaum était de retour en cour mais
la cause a été reportée rip reporté
parce que deux avocats qui était malade
alors il devra se présenter à nouveau le
10 mars donc monsieur applebaum qui fait
face je vous le rappelle à 14 chefs
d'accusation de fraude de corruption et
abus de confiance merci beaucoup
françois bonne soirée au revoir au
revoir